dandaka GSP in college basketball
analyst also radio host for 1070 the fan
and kind enough to join us how are you
coach six-four six-five about 250 trying
to lose weight I'm great how are you
guys doing great what did you take away
from last night your headline for last
night's draft would be what shooters
shooters and more shooters cam Johnson
to me kind of said what the NBA is about
DP I think that you know what we don't
hear Dan we've never heard this we never
heard the term rim protector and we
never heard the term point guard in the
NBA Finals we did and and it's it's
become shooters drivers and the game has
changed and that's kind of what I saw
you know where what a Zion Williams is
u3 is you - is he a 5 is you for you
know John Moran John Marant they think
can play with other guards it that's
what I took away from the whole deal day
and I just took away that the game has
changed the only team that really in my
mind I don't know what's gonna happen in
Cleveland but the only team in my mind
that said hey look we need a point guard
with Chicago when they got one but used
to be uh everybody needs a point
everybody needs a for every boy needs
rim protection you'll see that anymore
shooting shooting and more shooting but
what's the one team you would fit right
you would fit perfectly what's the one
team where you just shake your head and
go I don't know what they're doing I
hate to say this but my boys here in
Indiana and I'm getting ready I'm not
sure if I'm gonna rip I'm not sure
exactly what I'm gonna do but they take
a big kid and and one of the things that
I like to do is talk to Scouts along
along the way between the end of the
season in the draft and one of the
things that they said about this big kid
is that he needs to be tougher now if
I'm going to have a seven-foot player
from you know the Republic of Georgia I
want them to be a badass I want them to
be a tough dude with skill because
that's what I see in the league so you
already have two guys in Sabonis and and
Turner and all of a sudden you go to
your drafting another guy you know
hopefully it works out I'm gonna talk to
Kevin Prichard today on my show but you
know I sat there and wonder the team I
thought that did great because I love
like I love kam radish I thought I
thought Atlanta yeah I did - I did a
heck of a job I love kam rather stand
because he can shoot the daggone
basketball he's got sighs yeah I just as
I just mentioned about ten minutes ago
he could disappear I could watch he
could be on the floor and I didn't know
he was on the floor and I understand
what Zion and RJ Barrett that's possible
but there were just and maybe he just
didn't know what his role was on that
team but I I do like the possibilities
of I don't want to say potential the
possibilities of camera - with Atlanta
you know what again I go from the end of
the see I think the end of the season
for the giraffe tells you a lot you know
what I saw in that and this could be
dead wrong this could be dead wrong and
no one's ever going to admit it but I
almost saw the sign Williamson and RJ
Barrett had a little clique thing going
with each other and I don't know if
that's right but that's what it seemed
like to me and you know when you're in
it not nothing intentional nothing but
licious nothing but that's what I saw
and and I'm thinking to myself as I'm
watching I went back and watch them do
games and you're 1,000% right yeah it
showed a little bit I mean you got to
kind of look for it maybe I'm looking
too much for it that kind of thing but
it kind of showed a little bit but the
one thing that I did like about cam
raddish when I went back and watching
stuff while he did disappear he was not
afraid to take big shots
he made some miss some that's what you
do but he wasn't afraid on that stage
with those guys so I don't know I'm I'm
kind of big on him who had a good night
last night what didn't suck to be dying
Williamson last night knowing team-wise
well I do think Atlanta III do think
Atlanta and I do think the pelicans and
and the job and you know the Griffins
did they're getting all those picks for
Anthony Davis I don't think you know I
don't think you could have done better I
think that they had a great week I think
that overall when you look at what the
pelicans are going to be able to do with
their team it's a versatile team it's a
team that can click and I use modern
professional basketball DP because it's
just different but I do I think they had
a good night the most interesting night
to me was Cleveland you got John Beilein
who's a teacher and
have all these young guys and let's be
honest it's like of a lot different you
know you can win and play with freshmen
in the n-c-double-a basketball team and
rookies and Kyle professional basketball
DP yeah I don't know so I thought that's
the most interesting going forward but
look this this offseason as far as
belonging to the pelicans in my opinion
anyways ion doesn't work out I think
injury and and and you know that's
obvious but one of the things Dan he's
he's such a unique body and the season
is so long I mean let's let's think my
wife said the other day we're watching
NBA this and hockey are still going on
you know I mean I mean it's so long and
there's so much involved like people
think well be okay we got a game well if
you're Zion Williamson yeah you got a
game but you're gonna be out there 3-4
hours ahead of time working out with a
guy to get better I think he's got a
streamline his body and the other thing
Dan again he shoots it I think Zion
williamson's the smartest player in the
draft I think he's a absolute basketball
genius but the truth of the matter is he
doesn't shoot it gray and that line is
deep I remember I remember telling NBA
guys when Calbert Cheaney came out
Cowboys great not good great college
player all-time leading scorer play of
the year that he and I back in the early
90s he used to just shoot around before
practice and the NBA 3-point line was
too far for him it just was his stroke
didn't it you know I remember telling
him that and I ever since then Dan I've
watched that I've watched you know
college line one thing now they're
moving it back I just wonder if he'll be
effective enough shooter that's the only
thing that an injury that I see because
I do this he's brilliant
crazy athletic obviously and seems to
have a great personality who was the
best player you saw aside from the Duke
guys best player that you love game that
you broadcast that's a great question I
hate to say I mean the best player that
I broadcast in a game was jeez I really
like the Andre owner I really I really
liked him Dan I I don't I thought he was
great I thought that biggie bras
Akos played harder than anybody it
wasn't the best player but I thought
deandre honor when I did the ACC
tournament and you know you're sitting
there up close and you're watching I
will say this and it's gonna sound crazy
and people aren't gonna like it but as a
college player i take carson if you're
just in college now dan you know i mean
i'm not saying but carson Edwards was
electric even when he was shooting for
424 in a game I did against Indiana the
dude
I mean Vinnie Johnson is the only
comparison because he shoots the ball
the same way behind his head he jumps up
a mile even when he misses Dan it's like
whoa because he's he's not tall he's 511
six feet and Dan I'm telling you his
release on a jump shot at the apex is
probably as high as deandre on us I mean
there's a video of him shooting over
DeAndre on a you know jumping as high as
hunter can it so I don't think he was
the best like Hunter is such a good
fundamentally sound player but I'll tell
you this man Carson Edwards that dude's
electric you think he could start uh I'm
Sexton with Brad Stevens last night and
Brad was ecstatic to get him it was a
big name drop right there huge huge you
know Dan Patrick sent me a video last
night if you drop seven straight jump
shots while I'm trying to cook me and
it's a meat Friday so you know I love
sending that video to you I came into
the man cave by myself in the afternoon
and I put my phone up to record me
shooting jumpers just to let you know I
was in the laboratory shooting jumpers
and then dockage sends me a video of I
think you had a bottle of whiskey or
bourbon you had the grill yeah the grill
going on your backyard my son
it was home for the weekend we just got
done I don't know jacking around or
something and I'm sitting on the couch
that I just showed us how you look at
this fool drilling a jumper walk it back
to the video staring at me yeah I got
intimidated I'm not gonna lie I ran to
my room and locked the door
all right so what did Brad Stevens say
to you last night well when I was
texting with Brad Stevens he felt like
he thought you know what he knows these
two guys he got Romeo Langford and
Carson Edwards they felt like they're a
little lucky to get Edwards again it
just goes back to what basketball is
about the way it's set up to play
explosive felt like you know we all see
him we all see Edwards shooting jump
shots but I'm telling you when you see
him in person go to the rim I mean I'm
not saying again the in protection isn't
a big thing he was excited about having
it having both come and he felt like he
knew both of them better maybe than any
any guys he's ever been you know since
he's been in the NBA because obviously
he's from Indiana and has so many people
around and he just had an assistant like
a Cruz berry lead the Celtics and go
back to Purdue so he felt really good
about their potential as scorers and he
felt really good about how he knows how
they're going to fit in it's not a
guessing game bringing what goes to good
talk to you again Dan and have fun this
afternoon torching the Indiana Pacers
you're the best I think this afternoon
I'm gonna have a conversation with whom
who you who unit x2 this afternoon I
think I'll be texting with GM Kevin
Prichard and now I got I'm going fishing
this afternoon after my son is going to
know doctoring miracle fish you know
what I'm gonna be doing drinking whiskey
shooting threes no just shoot threes
just shittin you know what I do I shoot
lights out I have an electrician
standing by because I shoot the lights
out here he's on her hey could I say one
thing after that whole exchange I get it
I get a picture from you with like your
feet up a little glass looks like
bourbon and a cigar telling me what you
say you're like first-team all-american
and when it comes to the
your first team yeah I'm crazy yeah yeah
I'm like a plus-seven you know golf golf
handicap when it comes to drinking
tequila goodbye thank you thank you Dan
that's a Dan dockage ESPN college
basketball analyst and radio host 1070
the fan forum or Dan Patrick show tune
in the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]